the White House says that it is
cooperating with the Department of
Justice but is so far not explaining how
or why several top secret documents were
not in Secure locations one tranche was
found last November in an office Joe
Biden used before his time as president
though it wasn't made public until
Tuesday the U.S attorney general however
says that following an initial inquiry
additional papers with classified
markings were then found at Biden's
Wilmington Delaware home inside a locked
Garage in December with one more found
on Thursday morning the President says
that he takes classified information
seriously but the attorney general has
opted to appoint a special counsel to
investigate the possible unauthorized
removal and retention of classified
documents this appointment underscores
for the public the Department's
commitment to both Independence and
accountability in particularly sensitive
matters and to making decisions
indisputably guided only by the facts
and the law now this creates a political
headache for Biden after being highly
critical a former president Trump's
mishandling of documents Trump first
denied their existence then made bizarre
claims of declassification before
getting entangled in a legal battle over
their return National Security Experts
argue Biden's team handled this
differently because it secured the
documents and then gave them back in a
timely manner now at least initially
there's no indication of criminal
wrongdoing with Biden saying that he
didn't know about these documents still
a bipartisan group of lawmakers is
seeking an intelligence briefing on both
the Biden and Trump case along with the
damage assessment
Reggie kidney Global News Washington